richard était bon soir qui sortiront
pierre richard on vous présente plus pf
encore un peu avec votre vrai nom c'est
pierre françois martin laval vous êtes
un ex robin des bois et après maurice
barthélémy vous êtes le deuxième robin à
passer derrière la caméra vous êtes ici
ce soir pour un film qui s'appelle et c
est moi qui sort le 15 mars une espèce
de conte de fées moderne une histoire
d'amour mal barré au départ mais qui va
bien finir c'est très poétique sur le
pitch je préfère alors le pitch au début
julie depardieu et vous avait neuf ans
elle vous promet qu'elle vous épousera
quand vous irez dans les étoiles et 24
ans plus tard devenu cosmonautes vous
revenez à la charge mais julie a tout
oublié et elle va épouser quatre voix
l'a alors poussée par un père un peu
farfelue mais très aisément incarné par
pierre richard vous proposez un julie
depardieu de vous essayer pour une
journée quitte à dire non après voilà
alors si c'est un film très charmant il
n'y a pas de gros mots il n'y a pas de
cul ya pas de meurtre il n'y a pas de
personnage qui soit un [ __ ] six
espèces de comédie romantique
merveilleuse 1 et bien merci au revoir
alors on s'est fait de la mise en scène
est mis en scène les robins eric et
ramzy kadéos patrick bosso isabelle
nanty et puis un jour sur le tournage de
la tour montparnasse infernale christian
fechner vous dit tu devrais écrire ton
film a déjà commencé à travailler dans
votre dans votre tête mais fait chier
n'aime pas l'idée que le héros reste un
gamin comme ça qu'ils soient
complètement lunaire vous voyez chabat
ensuite vous voyez claude berri qui vous
dit c'est formidable malheureusement
chez pathé ça se passe pas aussi bien et
vous rencontrer laurent pétin et la lui
il aime l'idée il a envie de faire le
film il est très inquiet parce que vous
êtes j'étais obligé d'abandonner mon
rôle pour au port un jamel debbouze pour
un clovis cornillac vous dit que j'adore
alors que vous citez mais c'est vrai que
ça me faisait mal au derrière de données
mon saut arrière tu vois c'est tout
place de donner mon personnage a même un
acteur que j'adore comme djamel ou
cornillac parce que parce que je me
l'écrivait c'est ma vie quoique j'ai mis
dedans je m'attendais à ce qu'on me
propose et on m'a pas proposé de donner
mais difficile parce que tout le monde a
été a quand même un peu échaudé par
l'échec de recrues on a fait quand même
1 million 800 mille spectateurs mais
comme il y avait marqué dans toutes les
vitrines que c'était de la merde c'est
sûr que ça fait mal après ouais se
retrouve un peu son travail pour
certains d'entre nous et
ça m'a permis d'écrire un bon film et
ben voilà vous êtes là ce soir voilà
finalement et je ne reviens pas alors
vous c'est incroyable vous êtes de plus
en plus aimés de plus en plus considérée
au fil des ans alors maintenant on dit
du bien de vous dans télérama dans les
cahiers du cinéma les inrockuptibles
c'est bien vous avez eu un césar
d'honneur vous avez eu quand même là la
seule standing ovation de la soirée
c'est ouais c'était sympathique oui je
me fais plus plaisir même peut-être que
le césar c'était là là là là ça qui
c'est qui était debout c'est très
émouvant oui vous avez dit ce soir là je
suis heureux de paraître devant mes
pairs moi qui n'ai jamais été autre
chose qu'un un père déjà une très belle
phrase et ensuite c'était de voir votre
médecin pour savoir si je n'avais pour
longtemps mais c'est justement
maintenant un césar d'honneur c'est
un petit césar dans la route et oui
comment ça va ça va très bien c'est pas
un peu tard pour vous la scène un non
non je peux encore assumer cela aux
jambes ça va non non ce cas c'est
qu'après j'ai besoin d'un petit thé
chaud petite bouille est
en tous les cas peuvent dans ce film
vous avez vraiment créer un personnage
effectivement comme pierre richard était
un personnage et c'est yves robert vous
qui vous a dit ça et vous aviez impose
son univers est un personnage créé ton
cinéma ouais il m'avait dit je
mentionnerai toujours je me souviens
même veulent du lieu et de l'endroit
c'est la même chose
je me suis dit m'avait dit on nous
marchions le long d'une route du nord
une voie ferrée et m'a dit pire tu n'es
pas un acteur c'est un personnage ouais
je l'avais à moitié bien pris parce que
je mes pensées acteurs y compris que
j'étais plus un personnage qu'un acteur
et c'est pour ça que je me suis toujours
senti un peu bord cadre de la famille
des acteurs alors vous êtes également
sur scène avec détournement de mémoire
d'ailleurs le 27 mars au casino de paris
il ya beaucoup de rires dans ce
spectacle mais beaucoup d'émotion aussi
des choses insoupçonnées chez vous un
oui moi aussi d'ailleurs juste pareil je
soupçonnais pas ça ouais non mais c'est
vrai oui je sais pas mais évidemment je
joue sur du velours parce que je parle
de souvenirs avec des grands acteurs
avec lesquels j'ai pu travailler la
plupart des souvenirs seront
extraordinairement drôle parce que blier
car mes sens des c'était des phénomènes
et puis bien sûr il en est resté
quelques souvenirs très émouvant
notamment sur jean et sur bernard et
là ce sont des gens que les gens aiment
donc quand j'en parle avec cette émotion
est finalement gelée tous les soirs j'ai
jamais autant penser à
acquérir autant de ma vie cac armés
habillés puisque tous les soirs ils
vivent avec moi bon bah c'est émouvant
oui mais je pensais pas ça moi je
pensais faire rire ça fait rire beaucoup
parce que j'ai quand même des tas
d'anecdotes incroyable mais il y en a
une qui est incroyable c'est mireille
darc la première fois que vous tournez
avec elle est nue basses terres qu'elles
devaient s'avancer à moins de vente tout
nu et moi j'ai des relie et elle devait
avancer vers moi elle a dit pire tu me
regarde dans les yeux si tu tu incites
on regarde descend je t'en fous une
balle et j'ai tout ce que j'imaginais
pour trouver un bon prétexte pour
baisser les yeux d'éternuer il ya des
trucs invraisemblables six et quinze
jours par exemple vous jouez macbett
fait vous vous endormez sur scène
mais c'est vrai ça c'est vrai et c'est
vrai que c'est le système du tnp à
l'époque c'était de changer deux des
décors s'il n'y avait pas de rideaux il
y avait le noir les figurants on était
25 dans le noir on s'agite et pour
changer les décors et le remettent à
permettre la déclaration suivante dans
un minimum de temps pour pas et moi je
me suis endormi quand dans l'acte
précédent ce qu'on m'a tuer je suis mort
je me suis endormi et j'ai rien vu
jusqu'ici la suite elle survit au pied
de venue de la reine tout mon problème
était de savoir comment j'allais sortir
soit jeu je me levais naturellement chez
bonjour madame
ça me semblait pas vraiment soit je
restais coucher comme une carpette je me
disais après tout les divers ont bien
des peaux de tigres pour le poser le
pied magnifique soldats quoi c'était
soit je rampe et doucement vers la
sortie et c'est la troisième que j'ai
choisi je ne suis pas apprécié sa soirée
d'ailleurs c'est la pire parce que c'est
grand le tnp qu'on m'a vu on a vu
au ralenti
côté arsenal
alors pierre richard on va rester dans
le monologue pas faire d'interview
monologue
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
dieu que je suis moche pendant très
longtemps je me suis pas aimé ah ouais
ouais après j'ai commencé à m'aimer avec
la barbe et la géologie la couvée pour
un film mais et donc je continue à ne
plus aimer du tout bon sens vous n'êtes
pas mal on me l'a dit après oui
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
venez sur un plateau de télé
si je veux vraiment être frangy merde je
suis pas à l'aise ah oui là ça va vous
êtes gentils avec vous on peut être que
gentil qu'est-ce que je fasse des dons
en général je refuse ouais c'est vrai on
voit pas souvent je crois que c'est même
la première fois que vous venez à chier
ben c'était vraiment pour lui c'est
gentil merci pour moi
j'ai dit je serai grand
qu'est ce qui vous dit quand vous vous
levez le matin
je crois que je pense tout de suite à
manger oui je me lève avec la fin
et je me couche avec la soif d'ailleurs
ses terriers
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous vous
regardez dans un miroir
ça ressemble un peu à votre première
question c'est vrai oui si ça
je me suis dit septième édition
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
seul chez vous le soir devant un miroir
ou pas non non c'est important pas de
miroir
à vrai dire je suis pas souvent sur le
soir vous pouvez pas être seul j'ai du
mal à être seul ouais alors général suis
avec une femme quand même et donc si
elle est pas là je sors un oui on dirait
qu'il ya bien un moment où je rentre oui
on en revient à votre question du début
du sommet selon l'âge du rien puisque je
suis mort de fatigue et je dors fou
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez votre parcours
c'est ses 6
500 des sentiments mélangés
mais comme je suis quand même quelqu'un
très reconnaissant dans la vie je je me
dis que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance que
je suis à privilégier et que
j'aime tellement la vie j'aimerais bien
alors commencer le double
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
énervé
quand je suis énervé je dis d'aidé
j'ai dit des gros mots et brésiliens et
pourtant les par you are here ou la
halle est d'accord qu'est ce que vous
dites quand vous avez envie d'abandonner
ce métier
j'ai jamais eu envie de rendre ce métier
n'est jamais jamais le métier me morain
jusqu'à la main qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous regarder le journal télévisé
mon dieu ouais qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous ne recevez pas de scénario
pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle
le paresseux
qu'est ce que vous dites qu'on voit une
actrice qui veut coucher avec vous
je voulais je lui dis je dis oui
oui enfin bon
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez pas confiance en vous
la seule chose que je me dis
c'est c'est un souvenir de mon grand
père sur son lit de mort qui m'a dit tu
réussiras non j'ai pas confiance en moi
je me suis souvenu de ça et je crois
qu'il m'a il a porté cet ultime phrase
de cette son existence m'a toujours
conforté dans et d'un optimisme
caractérisée sur sûrement devenir ouais
qu'est ce que vous dites quand on vous
dit que vous n'êtes pas drôle
ça m'énerve
mais je reconnais à à quiconque de
trouver drôle ouais je ne dirais pas est
un con
même si je le pense un peu des fois
mais en tout cas je vous dirai pas
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez rien à vous dire
moi je ferme ma gueule
[Musique]
ouais c'est moi c'est la bande originale
du film qui sort le 15 mars
et de trois quarts
je tiens à
vous devez donner tout l'argent que vous
avez sur vous à une oeuvre caritative
je crois qu'il a pas loin de 3500
g sa
merci
des séries mois le 15
c'est pas contre cette idée de cartes on
en a vu des coups mais dénoncée pour
nous
soit fait
il ya une oeuvre caritative mais
laquelle la nouvelle peut demander à
bertrand delanoë il en a plein d'idées
autres cas étaient ainsi sas et
j'avais une époque un type qui avait mis
une heure dans un journal idée n'est
plus que trois jours pour envoyer aux
100 francs oui et il a touché des
fortunes si les gens disaient tu as vu
il ya plus de trois jours du shérif faut
vite il ya plus trois jours de paix pour
nous et il savait pas pourquoi rien et
ce type se faisait plaindrai pas il a
quand même fini par les rattraper au
bout de deux ans mais avec une fortune
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu